Aujourd'hui, c'est le printemps.
Les jours vont être plus longs que les nuits.
C'est une histoire de mécanique céleste.
Vous le savez, l'axe de rotation de la terre
est incliné à 23,5 degrés
et la terre tourne autour du soleil.
Bon, je sais ! mais on fait avec les moyens du bord...
L'hiver, l'hémisphère nord et moins éclairé.
Les nuits sont plus longues que les jours.
Aujourd'hui, 20 mars
la terre se trouve dans une position telle
que les deux hémisphères sont
éclairés de la même manière.
Le jour et la nuit font la même durée et dès demain,
les jours seront plus longs que les nuits.
Et je ne vous dis pas ça parce que
nous sommes en plein confinement.
Ahhh...Ça fait quand même du bien
de prendre un peu de hauteur,
une vraie "capsule de déconfiné".
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés
mais en reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo,
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain.